man what is special and point your
performance at was and you know you
could went out there and saying anything
but why Marvin Gaye's what's going on I
feel like the lyrics to that song just
really resonate what what's going on
right now you know we just we I need to
know what's going on we need to figure
out what's going on because it's
senseless it makes no sense for fathers
to lose sons sons to lose fathers
brothers to lose if it doesn't make any
sense it's kind of a call to action in
people neo also opened up about his
family including his newest bundle of
joy his four month old son Schaeffer
have the older siblings been helping out
yet yes they love in the dead there
Maddie wants to carry I'm like Maddie
you're only this much bigger than her
maybe not now you know Mason just wants
to play with him it's like maybe we
should let him learn to walk before you
get into that but yeah tell em today and
how's married life treating you so far
so good I'm loving ha about five months
in and you know we haven't killed each
other yet I guess that's a good sign I
think we call that the honeymoon phase
right there you go you go once the
honeymoon is over talk to me again and
see what we'll see what happened